Transcription: Hazel Koh
Relecteur: Hélène Vernet
Bonjour à tous.
Il y a quelques semaines,
j'ai fêté mon anniversaire.
J'ai fait mes trente ans,
et une amie m'a offert cette carte.
Cette carte, c'est un peu
comme le Calendrier de l'Avent.
On l'ouvre, mais on ne sait pas
avant, ce qu'il y a dedans.
Alors, je l'ai ouverte,
et il était noté :
« Life does not have to be
perfect to be wonderful »,
ce qui signifie : la vie n'a pas besoin
d’être parfaite pour être merveilleuse.
Je ne sais pas vous,
mais moi, je suis vraiment
d'accord avec cette citation.
Et il y a quelque chose
en quoi je crois encore plus,
c'est que la vie a besoin d’être
positive pour être merveilleuse.
Alors, voila : ma spécialité
à moi, c'est la positivité.
Je vais commencer par illustrer
la positivité avec cette image.
J’entend des réactions.
Oui, c'est du vin.
L’idée est d’illustrer le verre à moitié
vide et le verre à moitié plein.
Je n'ai pas pris de l'eau,
j'ai pris du vin.
Ici, moi ce que je vois,
ce sont deux verres.
Depuis que je suis toute
jeune, on me demande -
et j'imagine qu'on
vous l'a déjà demandé aussi -
est-ce que tu es plutôt le verre
à moitié vide ou le verre à moitié plein ?
Et honnêtement,
je n'ai jamais su répondre.
Une fois j'ai répondu
l'un, puis l'autre, puis l'un,
histoire de donner une réponse.
Alors voila mon interprétation
de cette image.
Pour moi, le verre
à moitié plein, c'est chouette,
dynamique, le verre se remplit,
c'est en mouvement et ça y va.
Mon interprétation
du verre à moitié plein :
c'est top, il y a de l'espace,
des opportunités, c'est génial.
Comme vous le voyez, mes deux
interprétations sont positives,
et c'est ma façon de voir la vie.
Alors, voila, avant
de parler de la positivité,
on va parler de la négativité.
La négativité, les Français
la connaissent très bien.
On est assez réputés pour être râleurs.
J'imagine que vous n'allez pas
me contredire là-dessus.
Alors pour comprendre ça,
pourquoi les Français
et les humains en général,
se concentrent plus
sur le négatif que le positif,
il faut remonter, il y a des
années et des années en arrière.
Lorsque l'humain devait
survivre au règne animal,
il devait, en permanence, être
aux aguets des dangers potentiels.
Et donc, pour ça, l'humain
fait appel à son cerveau reptilien,
qui est le cerveau de l'intuition
et de l'instinct de survie.
Les personnes
qui ont survécu, du coup,
sont celles qui ont le plus
développé ce cerveau reptilien.
Et donc, l’émotion liée
à ça, c'est l’anxiété.
Les personnes les plus anxieuses
sont celles qui ont survécu,
il y a des centaines d’années.
Ce trait d’anxiété s'est transmis
de générations en générations.
Aujourd'hui, on l'a tous, mais on n'en
a plus autant besoin qu’auparavant.
Voila d’où vient la négativité.
Je vais vous montrer comment
on pratique notre négativité.
Pratiquer sa négativité,
c'est super facile.
Il suffit de se concentrer
sur tout ce dont vous manquez,
que ce soit un appartement trop petit,
pas assez d'amis, pas assez d'amour,
pas assez de ci et de ça...
Concentrez-vous bien
dessus et vous verrez,
vous serez au top
au niveau de la négativité.
Et puis, si jamais, il y a
un événement un peu trop positif
qui vient s'incruster
dans votre vie négative,
surtout concentrez-vous
sur le fait que vous pouvez le perdre,
et toutes les peurs
qui viennent avec ça.
Vous l'avez compris, la négativité,
c'est facile pour nous.
Alors être négatif engendre des effets.
Les effets sont assez naturels,
je pense qu'on les ressent tous.
On se sent lourd, on a un nœud
dans l’estomac, ça nous fatigue,
on peut être triste : voila
les effets de la négativité.
Et ces émotions sont
très ancrées dans notre corps.
Du coup, elles restent avec le temps.
J'imagine que vous pouvez
y repenser : de temps en temps,
si vous entendez une musique,
ou sentez un odeur,
ça va vous rappeler un souvenir négatif.
Vous allez être triste,
ça va vous faire pleurer,
et paf ! le corps le saisît directement.
Voilà, ce sont les effets
de la négativité.
Alors maintenant, je vous propose
de passer à la positivité.
C'est quand même plus chouette.
Avant de plonger encore
plus dans la positivité,
je vais vous illustrer
pourquoi je crois que la positivité
fait une vie absolument merveilleuse.
Il y a cinq ans,
je suis partie au Canada,
en expatriation à Vancouver.
Là-bas, ils parlent uniquement anglais,
et mon niveau d'anglais, quand je
suis arrivée, n'était vraiment pas top.
Du coup, je me suis immergée.
J'ai fait des efforts,
j'ai travaillé mon anglais.
Aujourd'hui, le niveau d'anglais que j'ai,
je n'aurais jamais pu
penser l'avoir il y a cinq ans.
Du coup, je me suis posé des questions.
C'est là où j'ai eu ce déclic.
Qu'est-ce qui a fait que mon
niveau d'anglais ait pu arrivé là,
alors que vraiment,
je n'y aurais jamais pensé.
J'ai fait quelques recherches, et ça m'a
amenée, 70 ans en arrière, en 1949.
Il y a un psychologue qui s'appelle
Donald Hebb, qui est Canadien,
qui s'est intéressé à notre cerveau,
qui a essayé de comprendre
comment on pouvait manipuler, orienter,
décider de ce qu'on fait
avec notre cerveau.
Et il a découvert la plasticité cérébrale.
La plasticité cérébrale,
c'est une partie de votre cerveau
avec laquelle vous faites
ce que vous voulez.
C'est celle que j'ai sollicitée
quand j'ai appris l'anglais au Canada.
Cette plasticité cérébrale
est complètement malléable.
Alors...
Cette plasticité cérébrale,
je vais vous expliquer maintenant
comment la pratiquer
et comment la travailler,
parce que oui, ça se travaille,
tout comme la positivité.
Je vais vous donner
quatre conseils aujourd'hui.
Le premièr, c'est la gratitude.
J'imagine que vous en
avez tous entendu parler,
la gratitude, c'est
le fait de reconnaître
ce qui s'est passé
de positif pendant la journée.
Je la travaille au quotidien
depuis trois ans.
Pour mes vingt-sept ans,
j'ai reçu un carnet, par des amis,
que je trouvais plutôt joli,
et je me suis dit
que j'allais l'utiliser.
Ce que je fais, tous les jours,
avant d'aller me coucher,
c'est repenser à ce qui s'est
passé pendant la journée.
Les journées passent super vite
et il se passe plein de choses.
L'idée, c'est de noter ce qui
s'est passé de positif dans la journée.
En le notant, ça me permet de m'endormir
dans des conditions positives,
d'avoir une meilleure
qualité de sommeil
et de me réveiller
dans de meilleures conditions.
Je la travaille tous les jours
depuis trois ans,
alors oui, ça m'arrive d’oublier -
je suis juste humaine comme vous.
Du coup, je le fais le lendemain matin,
ou des fois, je fais deux jours pour un.
Ça, c'est le premier conseil.
Le deuxième conseil,
je vais l'illustrer avec ma main.
Là vous voyez ce côté,
une montre, des bagues, une main.
Moi, j'ai une autre perspective,
qui est celle-là : un petit soleil.
L'idée, ici, c'est de vous montrer
que vous faites ce que
vous voulez avec une situation.
C'est vous qui décidez
la perspective et l'angle de vue
avec lesquels vous voulez
regarder une situation.
Autre conseil : l'idée, c'est de repenser
à une réaction que vous avez eue
avec laquelle vous n’êtes pas
confortable, une réaction négative.
Je vous invite à faire une pause
et à repenser à cette réaction,
à l’émotion présente
qui était là pour vous,
et à imaginer un scénario positif.
Quelle est l’émotion
que vous auriez aimé avoir ?
Quelle est la réaction
À force de travailler ça,
ça va inculquer en vous
des choses positives
et des réactions positives.
Et mon dernier conseil,
je vous invite à le suivre dès
ce soir quand vous rentrez chez vous.
Vous prenez une feuille blanche
et vous notez tous vos succès,
tous ceux que vous avez eus
au cours de votre vie,
et ensuite, toutes les qualités
et les forces que vous avez,
et vous mettez
cette feuille sur votre frigo.
L'idée, c'est d'afficher
ce dont vous êtes fiers,
parce que, comme on l'a vu,
on a tendance à
se concentrer sur la négativité.
En affichant ça, vous le verrez
au quotidien, vous le relisez.
Vous en faites ce que
vous voulez, mais ça sera là,
et ça vous envoie des ondes positives.
Donc, voilà mes quatre conseils.
Ensuite, c'est bien beau la positivité,
mais franchement, ça sert à quoi ?
Quels sont les effets ?
Les effets, il y en a plusieurs ; je vais
en partager quelques-uns avec vous.
Le premier effet,
c'est le cercle vertueux :
plus il a y de positif dans votre vie,
plus vous êtes concentré sur le positif,
et moins vous avez d'espace
pour le négatif.
C'est le cercle vertueux
qui se fait automatiquement.
Un deuxième effet positif,
c'est la résilience.
La résilience, c'est
la capacité à résister
à des événements douloureux ou difficiles.
Les personnes positives,
du fait de leur façon de voir
les choses, leur perspective,
ont une meilleure résilience
aux challenges de la vie.
Oui, les personnes positives
n'ont pas une vie Bisounours.
On a tous une vie avec des
ups et downs ; c'est juste la vie.
Les personnes positives ont une meilleure
perspective sur ces moments challenging.
Un autre effet de la positivité,
c'est la vie sociale.
Les personnes positives, du fait de leur
gratitude et leur façon de voir la vie,
tissent des liens sociaux
de meilleure qualité avec leurs amis.
Il y existe un TED à propos
de ce qui rend les gens heureux.
Est-ce que c'est la voiture,
le statut social, le métier ?
Désolée, je vais vous spoiler, mais
c'est la qualité des relations sociales,
pas la quantité, mais la qualité.
Le dernier effet,
c'est la confiance en soi.
Une personne positive va toujours
voir le côté positif des choses.
Et lors d'un échec, elle ne va pas
le voir comme un échec,
mais plutôt comme
une expérience de vie,
un apprentissage, juste une étape
à passer pour continuer dans la vie.
Des effets positifs à la positivité,
il y en a encore plein d'autres :
l'innovation, la créativité,
la mémorisation.
On a vu la négativité,
on a vu la positivité,
mais la base de tout ça, c'est quoi ?
Ce sont les émotions.
Une émotion, c'est un message
envoyé par votre corps
pour vous donner une information.
Et si là, tout de suite -
il est quatorze heures trente -
vous vous concentrez sur l’émotion
présente pour vous maintenant,
est-ce que vous êtes plutôt dans la joie,
dans la peur, dans la lassitude ?
Quelle est l'émotion
qui est là pour vous maintenant ?
Dites-vous que cette émotion,
elle est déjà partie.
Une émotion ne dure que quelques secondes.
Ce qui prend le relais
de l’émotion, c'est la mémoire,
ce sont les pensées ruminatives
qui vont entretenir cette émotion.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Le mois dernier, j’étais en déplacement
avec des collègues au Texas.
On a pris un Uber, et j'étais assise
à l’arrière, au milieu.
Je vois les voitures freiner devant,
mes collègues qui discutaient
avec le chauffeur,
et là, mon ventre s'est mis à se serrer,
j'ai commencé à être angoissée
parce que je voyais l'accident venir.
Finalement, le chauffeur a vu
que les voitures ralentissaient,
et s'est mis à freiner,
et il ne nous est rien arrivé.
Mais mon cerveau a commencé à paniquer :
et si on avait eu un accident,
que serait-il arriver ? etc.
Là, j'ai fait le choix de me dire :
« Non, je ne veux pas donner
d'importance à cette émotion
qui de toute façon ne sert plus à rien,
vu que le problème est résolu. »
C'est à ce moment-là que vous avez
le choix, lorsqu'une émotion vient,
de choisir la positivité ou la négativité.
La positivité, selon mon point de vue,
c'est comme cette goutte d'eau
qui tombe dans l'eau.
Ça se répercute. Ça se diffuse.
Par exemple, si vous êtes
avec une personne qui rit ou sourit,
ça vous donne envie de rire ou sourire.
Eh bien, la positivité,
c'est exactement pareil.
Lorsque vous êtes une personne positive,
vous avez de l'impact sur
les personnes autour de vous,
qui elles-mêmes en ont
sur les personnes autour d'elles.
Alors, quel est l'impact que
vous décidez d'avoir aujourd'hui ?
Merci.